[Music]
well this morning on the dish chef and
food writer David Tanis born in Ohio he
grew up with a love of cooking often
trying his hand at recipes that he saw
in the New York Times and in college in
California he found himself more often
in the kitchen than the library
eventually ended up in Berkeley working
for Alice Waters in the early days of
her influential Chez Panisse
beginning an association that lasted for
a quarter century now lives here in New
York where he's best known as the author
of several acclaimed cookbooks including
his latest David tennis market cooking
published last October chef David
Tennant's good morning welcome to the
dish thank you nice to be here a
fabulous spread tell us what you what
you got for us well we have very simple
food because that's the kind of food I
like to cook we have a beautiful spinach
salad with Gruyere cheese and eggs and
bacon and for a little more bacon in
your meal
there's an onion tart that's based on an
Alsatian onion Todd called flam Akutan
we have roast chicken with roasted
garlic very simple but very delicious
and for a little more spicy situation
with vegetables Indian spices so the
cauliflower easton it's cauliflower is
bright and cheerful so i'm just curious
how does a man who grow up on tater tots
huh and bird's-eye frozen food end up
whipping something like this up indeed I
don't know how things happen in life
yeah but where did your passion for food
really start I have to say when I was a
little kid I could always tell where the
butter was the butter but it wasn't at
our house but when it was at somebody
else's house I knew the taste of butter
and good bread yeah so when I was in my
teens I started beginning to bake bread
just learning from recipes
mainly from the New York Times actually
and then when I was in college I did
spend quite a lot of time in the kitchen
that's where my my interest in cooking
sort of took hold
so how did you really get your first
start when you began well some people go
to cooking school and some people learn
as they go and there's a process called
fake it until you get know how to do it
and so I was pretty good at faking it
until I was actually qualified
and for books under your name report
harder writing the books or actually
doing the cooking in the kitchen writing
I think is a little bit harder than
cooking but they both require you know a
certain amount of skill yeah you were
telling us beforehand I mean you're very
involved in in your cookbooks not just
in the writing but in you prepare all
the food yourself
I want it well because for me cooking is
a visual expression an artistic
expression and I want to be involved in
how the how the book looks from the
photographs to the design I don't want
the food I want the food to look natural
I don't want to look styled yeah what is
exactly market cooking it sounds like
some fancy European thing that's only
accessible abroad no no it's the oldest
I mean it's the oldest way to cook you
go to the market that's where the food
is
you look but around and you see what
looks best and you take something home
and cook it that's market cooking and
anybody can do this anyone can do it you
can do it if you have a farmers market
in your neighborhood you can do it at
the grocery store early on you had an
interest in art yeah right yeah and you
see if a connection between food and art
absolutely yeah what is that connection
for you well I mean it is a kind of way
of expressing oneself visually you know
but the theatre involved as well because
you know when you're in a restaurant the
show starts and then you know the it
goes to the end but in the beginning so
much about how the food looks on the
plate it's artistic yeah so what's next
for you chef's you've done the cooking
you've done the books you have arrived
what would you like to do next what
would I like to do next well I'd like to
go away and do a little research on a
very small island we might just join you
there chef before you sign this I'd like
to ask this delicious meal who would you
like to share this with past or present
that is the hardest question really it
is really hard but I thought about it
and thought about it and I thought
Harriet Tubman what a great choice
actually because you know she was so
important with all of the things
getting rid of slavery and also very
important with women's rights yes and I
think she would deserve a good meal yeah
absolutely
excellent thank you so much very much
for joining us what a delicious feast
thank you and for more on the chef
tennis and the dish head to our website
at CBS this morning calm